[Music]
but welcome back everyone to the data
science hangout and i hope you're having
a great week
also just want to say hello to anyone
that's joining for the first time too
it's great to meet you
i'm rachel and i'm the host of the data
science hangout
and so this is an open space for the
whole data science community to connect
and chat about data science leadership
questions you're facing
what's going on in the world of data
science
so if you ever want to go back and maybe
re-watch some of the
the older sessions
or share this with someone who's missed
it they'll be recorded and shared up to
the r studio youtube as well
we really want this to be a space where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
so there's three ways you can ask
questions you can jump in live and
raise your hand on zoom
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and if you're like in a coffee shop or
something or you don't want to read it
out loud you can put a little star there
and i'll i'll know to read that one too
we also have a slido link where you can
ask questions anonymously and tyler's
going to share that in the chat in just
a moment
but i do just want to reiterate that
we'd love to hear from everyone no
matter your level of experience or area
of work as well
but i'm so happy to be joined by my
co-host for today prabha
prava is a senior director of analytics
and supply chain solutions at flex
and probably i'd love to just kind of
turn it over to you for a minute to have
you introduce yourself and maybe share a
little bit about the work that you do on
your team
great hi everybody i'm prabha i
i'm based in austin texas i work for
flex
flex is a fairly large company largely
unknown because we are a contract
manufacturing company we mainly do
manufacturing in the electronic space
so i am part of the
supply chain organization at flex and i
lead analytic data and analytics for the
supply chain organization
and luckily or unfortunately in the last
couple of years
um i can say the word supply chain and
everybody knows what i mean or what i do
prior to that i'd have to explain what
supply chain means
that hurdle has been removed in the last
couple of years
um
my team
does data and analytics
um i have been with flex for almost 15
years now i have a
cross-functional team data scientists
analysts
software developers and we
provide data and analytics solutions
for flex so that's what i do
awesome thank you prabha and while we're
waiting for questions coming from
everyone i'd love to ask you what is
something that you're most excited about
in data science right now
in in the last
um
you know one and a half or maybe even
two three years
um
i am quite excited about the level
of
acceptance from
the executives and top management
that data and analytics can bring value
um
and it that you know
people hear about google and big data
and machine learning all of that's been
going on for about 10 years
um
the
code pandemic in the last two years has
accelerated that specifically for flex
because we are manufacturing against
global manufacturing and supply chain
company
supply chain is very
data intensive and so that helps to get
the buy-in
but just beyond flex
i talk to my peers in other
industries and companies
there is a growing acceptance that
data analytics data science
can
bring value uh to the bot to the top
line to the bottom line of a company
um
executives are asking for it
um you know we want exit executives to
ask tough and hard questions that we can
answer with data and data science
on the flip side of it
um there is more recognition
that hey let's do some good data science
work that can help define strategy so
that
that circle i see more acceptance within
uh flex but also talking to
peers and friends and network um across
industries and companies so that's
um there is recognition
and there is a
[Music]
high growth opportunity and acceptance
um
[Music]
from
key decision makers
that's great
and to maybe help us all kind of
understand a little bit more about some
of the projects that you work on
could you kind of give us an example of
maybe one that you're most excited about
or something that maybe got the most
recognition across the company
yeah so
um
i'll talk about two projects one they're
at different
life cycle stages the first one is a
more mature
um say project um
at flex we make a lot of electronics
things we make things for amazon google
cisco's of the world
um so we
we buy about three different i mean
think of your laptop or your mobile
phone right a mobile phone is typically
made up of
200 different
skus or components um so flex in total
buys about 3 million unique
components
um you know ics capacitors plastic parts
and so forth
so this project is looking at the set of
parts that we buy
um and and saying what should be the
correct pricing that flex pays for each
of these parts right so that's been one
of our i would call it our flagship
success project um and we've made
many millions of dollars
in that project over the last three
years
that it is
even in a big large company like flex
the amount of money that we have made
has
helped get the attention of senior
executives
so that they are paying attention to
data and analytics can help
now this a second project that i would
like to talk about is
um it's in say much in a you know an
infancy or child
status of its
of its growth
that is market sensing right market
sensing whether it is by web scraping or
subscribing to external market data um
and
giving
the functional and leadership teams
what is it looking ahead
you know um
so these are like you know
because of this supply chain
market constraint
um
the question in
the organization is more on what is in
store what
the
the future
certainty or uncertainty people are more
interested to learn about it um and
um
it's not just my team but you know the
leadership team at flex have said hey we
want to get more real-time data we want
to look ahead we want to be able to make
decisions
and
from a data science and analytics
function area of growing that within an
organization
i think it's important to get that first
first or second or third wins build that
trust with
the
your partners um and then take it from
there
that's awesome prabha and i i guess that
can be seen as an upside of kovid too
that now everyone is so much more
familiar with supply chain
yes well you know
we've all heard of you know you're not
able to make enough cars to keep up with
the demand because we need more ic chips
and cars
um every product that flex makes has
semiconductor chips in it because we
mainly do it and
we live you know me and my colleagues in
the supply chain organization
um live that eight hours a day
uh zach i see that you had put a
question into the zoom chat and i'd love
to have you ask that one live
yeah sure so
just expand on the question but more you
talked about how you've been using data
for around 10 years
with supply chains i presume that was
about getting the just-in-time model
like where the thing where your supply
just arrives literally just before it
needs to be used
and therefore you're not having all that
storage cost
how has that changed with covered and
because of course we all know about the
delays that the supply chain is having
is there a change in thought about how
just in time model may not work because
customers aren't happy with
it not arriving in time are you
thinking about putting more
like time between arrival and usage
that is a great question um
yes there is consent so the just-in-time
model
came about with say dell and other big
companies
optimizing on cost
right um
now
even prior to covered um
the optimizing on cost was make do all
the manufacturing in a low cost region
you're optimizing on cost um and store
inventory somewhere to supply us
um that model worked you know it's been
around for 15 20 years
and even prior to covert the you know
the low cost countries are not that low
cost anymore um so that thinking of
um you know
uh it's not just just in time but other
strategies and manufacturing and supply
chain that are associated with it
that thinking has been changing in the
last 10 years
and
with covert
um
that
cost optimization of the supply chain
which used to drive everything else
has gone lower in importance
so
that is
also where
the decision makers and the executives
want
more data
to balance their decision and not just a
decision being made on one parameter
very interesting thank you
i know you you talked a little bit about
like the business coming to you with
more and more questions now or wanting
to see like what's coming down the road
and i was wondering what are some of the
effective strategies to kind of build
that collaboration
in partnership with the business
um
i will stress upon the word partnership
right um
um
and i it's a struggle it is
a struggle and a fight within
a large organization
to say hey an iep and an analytics team
i want to be an equal
so
the
business teams potentially have
the flaw of looking at it and analytics
teams as service providers um i think
that's the first
um say or
first battle that we have you know that
i have fought and i think is fundamental
we have to be equal partners i think
go you know have the honest conversation
with um
your partners to say we are partners
which means
you tell us what to do and we will we
also have the power to tell what needs
to be done by you
um
and
create common goals um the common goals
i think enables this collaboration and
partnership um define upfront
what is success for the company and that
is a few steps beyond
uh model development and model
deployment
um so
we get
caught a lot in you know the analytics
and data science community gets caught a
lot in
the net the
new technology or you know deep learning
what is the next cool thing to do
however
the business value created by a
descriptive analytics dashboard like a
dollar created by a descriptive
analytics dashboard
is the same as a dollar created by a
deep learning model so
where i'm trying to get to is
set what the goals for the goals will be
different for an analytics team versus a
business team the business team will be
focused on dollars
um now set what those criteria of
successes that enables collaboration and
partnership
how the
you know descriptive analytics or
prescriptive or predictive analytics
is
the how part of how we get there in in
my head
um
well
me and my team we are not
we are not a research team we do some
research but we are an applied analytics
data science organization
um
for flex and and i'm
guessing this is true for 90 or a vast
majority of companies out there
analytics is a means to an end
um if your if your focus is for yourself
and your company
is research focused
then that statement does not hold
through
for all other
analytics data and analytics is the mean
student
thank you pravan i am i just want to
remind everyone too if you want to ask
questions on slido tyler just reshared
the link
but i see
uh amziani and apologies if i'm
pronouncing your name that you asked a
great question about a datathon that
you're participating in and would love
to have you ask that question
i'd be happy to to read it out loud too
and if you want to jump in with any
other context feel free to
but the question was hi i'm an aspiring
data scientist and i'm participating in
a datathon and while going through the
resources i find myself diving into
different things that sometimes aren't
related to what i need to do
even when trying to do personal data
prod
projects and then get overwhelmed
so the question is around how do you
stay focused and what's a good plan to
learn data science
um
is does the person who asked the
question do they
uh are they a student do they work for a
large
do they work for a company can
i want to understand the context of the
question to help to answer it in a
better way
is the person online
they're online but if you feel free if
you feel comfortable jumping in feel
free to add
contacts there or you can put into the
chat too
um you said they're a data analyst with
experience with python and sql
okay um so if you are a
practitioner or an individual consulting
person
then
you want to have value in learning
different things right so you have
you're adding more
um
arrows to your arsenal or curve um
again and if you are working for an
organization i think it goes back to
this common definition of success
along with your partners in the business
teams
um
whether it is pythonx sqlr julia go
whatever it is
i think that is irrelevant when it look
when you look at it from a business
perspective and context um it is a means
to an end
is the analytics that is being
that is the output of the data science
process is it
giving insight something giving insights
to the decision makers something new and
then that they can base their strategy
in a
in a more
robust way so i think the context is
important um and you know i have
myself i'm
a
part data scientist
i have data scientists in my team and
software developers and it depends on
personal interest right so there are
people in my team who want to understand
the business context and want to learn
how to you know they want to spend time
on these things
there are software developers and data
scientists who don't want to
who want to spend more of their time
coding and don't want to be in meetings
and don't want to talk to the business
teams they don't care to learn and it's
a to some extent there is a
it is a personal preference but i think
to be successful in an
organized in a large enterprise or
organization there needs to be
the contextual element and that needs to
get represented within
the team that
gives the output to meet business
and that's how i would um you know
the two different options that's how i
would characterize where they should
focus their times on time on
thank you
i i feel like i have a similar
experience with that too like if you're
trying to solve a specific
problem or question and you're
a beginner
like i am as well
you sometimes can get overwhelmed with
all the different directions that you
could possibly
go with that and then get sidetracked by
so many like
different different processes you could
take or different packages or
i um
i see christian you had a comment on
getting sidetracked one one thing i'd
like to add to it right yes
even if
personally
as a data scientist you don't want to
invest time to understand say that
domain expertise
that's okay
but are you organizing your
project team such that that expertise is
covered and let's say
you know we work in the supply chain
industry um say procurement or buying
things um as part of this successful
project team
that we made all this money from there
are procurement experts here in that
team
so they bring that knowledge
and
[Music]
that common definition of success is
they are contributing to it
and that helps so even if individually
you make the choice or a data scientist
makes the choice that i want to spend
more time learning new data science
things
please make sure that the project team
those
skill sets and capabilities are gone
definitely but
i am i see there's a great conversation
happening in the chat as well in this
topic and christian i was wondering if
you might be willing to share
what you put into the chat as well
sure
um
yeah
so just from my perspective right um
and it's it is a little vague because i
don't know exactly what you're getting
sidetracked on right if you're working
on data and then you're all of a sudden
sidetracked by a video game that's bad
if you're working on
data and you find a quirk in your data
right that maybe isn't necessarily
related to that specific question you're
trying to solve that's not bad
you've actually just found something you
i would encourage i encourage my
analysts to explore those things um most
data
successful data scientists uh that i
know of are curious people by nature
anyway
and you can end up driving more value
and
you can actually pull this back a little
bit to
i've found coming back with little extra
pieces like that if i'm going through
and somebody asked me to solve a
question for them i can solve that but
then i also found this extra little work
and then i come back and i say hey by
the way did you know this and we could
do that
that you can really build a really
strong partnership that way right we're
always walking a tricky line because
data
to some extent always is going to be a
customer service but we are not google
assistant we're not alexa we're not siri
right you can't just poke us with a
stick
ask us to do something we still have to
use our brains
and come back
so we're always walking that line and
that's one of the ways we can do it is
by giving a great answer but then also
giving extra information that they
didn't even know they wanted but we
found
i love that christian thank you so much
i'm gonna pause for a second to see if
anyone else wants to jump in dude
i can jump in
sure
go ahead
i was gonna say as i've talked about it
a couple times right
i'm in the same sort of place where i'm
new to this
um i'm always looking to learn and i'm
very much someone that's always been
sidetracked
uh good and badly i will always be
sidetracked um
i think the important thing is making
sure you've got that deadline set and
you always have constant reminders
uh
for me it's
i have an apple watch so of course it
says stand up every hour so i use that
as a like a
reminder am i on track
and if i'm not on
and
one
and if i'm not on track
is what i'm doing beneficial to me
if it's not then i will sit back go back
to my plan
if it is beneficial then i'll continue
it for the next hour and then i'll ask
myself again
so
that's how
me he always gets distracted keeps on
track
because of course deadlines are
important because otherwise you won't
have that job seeing
uh
so yeah that's how i do
thanks zach
brian i know you're about to add
something too i don't want to jump to
the next question yet
i like to sort it out between
learning on your own and obviously on
the job to zach's point you got to make
the deadlines you got to get the job
done
um
at the same time as
to learn something
you know think about then i mentioned
this when i when i was in the hangout is
45 minutes every day
um do your coursework do something learn
something you're
as a data person
you're in a marathon
it's not six months it's not a year
you're enough of your you know if you
want it this is a career you need to be
learning every day every week every
month and it's not going to be
huge steps along the way
um
and so you know you take that half hour
every day build a foundation that's the
biggest thing you need a foundation
and a little bit of statistics and a
little bit of everything
before you can go out and build that
project
to use an example a long time ago when i
got into text analytics and nlp
i literally read papers for three weeks
before i even committed one line of code
because it took so long to just figure
out all the different convolutions of
the libraries and the terminology then
nobody bothered to explain any of the
papers
and finally when i did it one day it was
like literally three weeks later i did
the first
tokenization
word cloud and phrase cloud and bigrams
and it all came together but it wasn't
like
you know i knew how to do that right
away and i was just gonna go bang it out
in a session you know or two hours
overnight it was literally three weeks
of reading
every paper i could find out there
um and so you have to look at that that
way you're gonna have to you have to
spend time build a foundation there's no
magic bullet there's no
um
quick sprint it's you're in it for a
marathon
thank you brian
i love finding these kind of questions
where everybody has different thoughts
and tips on them and we can kind of dive
deep
into them and millie i saw you had a
great recommendation as well if you
wanted to
to chime in too
yeah right now i'm like in a data
science fellowship so i i definitely
know the feeling of like learning and
feeling like you're getting sidetracked
so these days i've been using the
pomodoro timer um i think like the
standard is that you're like you have
focused time for like 20 25 minutes and
then five minute breaks in between each
and like each little section and you can
do like up to 12 in a day if that's your
goal at least that's what i have
um but yeah i have like section time for
like my project work or if i want to
like dig deep into something like right
now i'm like trying to like work on my
own like little professional website so
i set these little tasks
and do like a solid two hours of work is
like i think my limit right now but it's
like a good way to like get a lot of
stuff done in a little bit of time um
and feel like i'm making progress
so personally that is a challenge for me
also holding attention to do data
science work
actually in the new year i did make a
resolution
that i will
not keep my email inbox open all the
time
so there are some days
where i am
adhering to my resolution and i only
open email two three times a day um and
there are some days where i fail
but that has helped uh it you know
at work
um
email has become
like a chat
people expect responses in a couple of
minutes but i've told my you know close
collaborators that this is my plan for
2022 and it is even in the last one and
a half weeks i see that it has helped
i'm able to do more focused work
that's awesome i need to do that too
instead of jumping around from so many
things all the time
um thank you i'm ziyani for opening up
that discussion too
i i see libby you had to ask the great
question earlier as well would you want
to ask that one live
sure can you hear me yep i can
awesome okay so i was wondering if
and i hope i ask this question in an
eloquent way if i don't please uh feel
free to ask me to elaborate
um a lot of the stuff that you were
talking about was
demand sensing demand planning and like
you know reducing costs for sourcing and
stuff like that and i was wondering if
there has been any analysis done on
planar processing
like when you have scenario planning and
you have software that planners are
using has there been any analysis on the
way that planners use the software so
that processes can be
um
made more efficient
and timing can be saved and stuff like
that that's been really really
interesting to me right now i'm moving
into a role where i'm looking at
customer data customer interaction data
and so coming from where i was the
summer i was at kanexis thinking about
the way that planners are actually
clicking and using and
the troubles that they have with their
workflows has there been any look into
that or is there value there
kinax is this actually one of the is the
planning tool used at flex um
i think the
um i think are you asking about from a
process is a question from a process
perspective yes
okay so
from a process perspective this
i let me talk about you know not
specific we can access
or not specific to the kinexis usage at
flex but generally using software and
adhering to
uh business processes and
data analytics and a software
application helping in that business
process like
um at an even higher level it is change
management
um
so
in a large organization or in
when you talk to an experienced
domain expert who's done their job for a
long time based on
experience intrinsic knowledge
just having done that job for 5 10 12 15
years
it is change where
now the data analytics
says or a piece of software or a
computer says
here is the right answer just go execute
on this right answer right so that
fundamentally is change management
and
it it comes you know there are many
layers to it there is the individual
accept not ex accepting is probably a
wrong word individual
uh saying huh this
this piece this computer thing uh can
help me do my job better or
the
other
reaction could be
i know to do this job what is this
computer thing telling me right yeah the
starting point at an individual level
and then you can
then
that set of individuals come to like a
team organization etc so it is
fundamentally change management at
individual level it is um
when it's an individual now that
at a team level and an organization
level it is change management um and
that is dependent on
um
you know some teams
do it well some companies do it well um
some do not you know
in my experience just saying hey here is
a new piece of software use it for your
work
is a
[Music]
sure way to hit a dead end very soon um
so um that has to be sold
both at
uh the say
at executive level and also at
executional level the people who are
actually doing the day-to-day job
um
does that address your question really
it fundamentally is change management um
and sort of yeah
in some extreme case um you just have to
take away the old way of doing things
and say it's not unacceptable right
that's the very extreme
like the individual is not able to do
their day job the old way
uh that's the most extreme case
that's the forced case of change
management and that happens and
sometimes it needs to happen yeah
right yeah thank you i i some part of my
question was kind of
is there any analysis done on like
adoption rates like how many planners
are using the tool versus how many are
actually
changing suggestions that are given to
them by an algorithm due to some kind of
aversion to that like you were saying
like i know my job better than this
computer
we do
we capture data on
multiple levels of data capturing going
on in our set of tools
the first one
[Music]
and in each level shows
let's say a maturity level the first one
is
let's say we introduce a piece of
analytics or applica an application
there are potentially say 20 people who
do that function who are that functional
group how many of the 20 use it how
often do they use it and we know that um
the expected usage is
100 times a week because we know the
amount of usage or the amount of times
that a business process needs to run in
in the team or in the company
um so then you can start measuring from
users and usage what percentage of the
usage is happening
in the software or analytics in that
business process so that's the first
level
we do measure for our applications usage
and usage then the second level maturity
is
um it's almost like a b testing so to
speak um
are the results you know what are the
kpis metrics and results that are out
that are the outputs of the process
these are not
uh this is not model accuracy this is
not analytics metrics or model metrics
these are business process metrics
is it changing is it better
then that builds up that is the
effectiveness
sorry that's the that's a measure of the
effectiveness of the process
um as it relates to this common goal
right so that's the next level of
maturity now these data points start
giving us
um
start giving
two
i think that two
if it is all good then there are two
very um say high value data points here
one
the business process is enhanced because
of the introduction of the software or
analytics
then the second thing is the closed-loop
process there are going to be aspects
where
humans make decisions
which the software doesn't know about i
mean that's the difference between model
and reality um now
once developing that closed loop process
is really hard
but the more you're able to do that
the better this
engine or piece of software becomes um
but to
[Music]
be able to do you know the
chicken and the egg problem um to be
able to get everybody to contribute to
that closed loop we first have to prove
that the process is enhanced by doing so
so
those are the multiple layers of say
heard or multiple hurdles
that are across and it is very important
to have
to collect data to collect metadata on
your product
on the process
on um
on the business outcomes
that was super helpful brahma thank you
so much
thank you prabha and also i think taking
that a bit further i saw there were some
anonymous questions that came into
around working with the business and one
was
how do you measure understand the
business value of your work so like
earlier when you say millions for
example or like especially if a data
scientist is lower in the org chart
how do they go about measuring that
impact
it's a actually it's a simple answer i
go back to the first thing i said
we are partners
i i
do not accept the statement that a data
scientist or an id person is lower in
the org chart
um
to people that i work and have built
trust with i can say it to their face um
but you know
in a very extreme case sometimes i just
say hey
look at your paycheck look at my
paycheck it says the same company logo
on the top so we are equals we are
colleagues
and we are partners
[Music]
it is a
sometimes a hard statement to make um
but i i have made this statement to my
colleagues
um
and
i think we we have to we are not a
service organization i think we have to
fight for our rightful place as equal
partners so i will not accept
the premise that
a data scientist or an i.t person is
lower in the org
now i think the first part of the
question was
how do we measure success it's a very
simple answer dollars
um at least
um
in a company or in an enterprise
everybody you know the
the capitalism and
the company exists to make money so that
is a there is no more common um
[Music]
agreement on what success means right um
analytics is a means to an end the end
is usually um if it is
i would you know i i if i have three
project proposals and i have to
prioritize what my team works on
um i give a lot of advantage to
who has which
uh business team who made the proposals
have thought through this problem of
what you know what do they want us to do
are they able to clearly articulate
how a model or a piece of software will
help them make their
business case better what are the kpis
that they want to measure i mean the so
the software application will measure it
for them
but they need to tell me
uh well they are the business teams are
the experts
in saying what kpis are important for a
given business process
um
what
are the
data and analytics can
can potentially help them
to measure what is known to them
but also can help them you know they
know that you know today but many
business teams know that something is
important but they don't have an
easy way to measure it and data
analytics and software can help them so
they can give them the known known
answers in some cases it can also give
them the known unknown answers going
forward
and i think
those are all intermediate steps to
final value which is dollars right so if
multiple there are multiple projects in
front of me i look at
the maturity of
the request or the business thinking
that goes from request to analytics
model to kpis to dollars and if a
business team comes to me with a more
well thought out and articulated
proposal
and i'm
they get the resources are you know that
is a key
[Music]
point in
my decision making for prioritization
that's super helpful trava
and i'm i was wondering if you do also
give feedback to people on their
proposals like oh we didn't prioritize
this because you didn't make this clear
yeah yeah that that you know they
they they lose out there is penalty for
them not doing this initial work that
they
are
not the first in queue
i know you um oh i sounded like someone
had a question is someone gonna jump in
i um i know you mentioned like
it's simple it goes back to the
partnership with the business
but i will say
making really like those relationships
and partnerships
probably isn't simple for all of us so i
was just wondering like what are the
most important factors
um and this is a question actually
earlier on slido that help you establish
a strong partnership with your business
stakeholders
um
time is a very
key component
you know
my partners today when my closest
partners in the business teams today
were not my partners
um
three four five years ago they were not
this
they were not the same partners that
they are today that they were say even a
year ago so
you need to give time
i mean it's with any relationship it
gets stronger with time and trust and so
building trust
is you know time and trust are very
important um
but again
demanding to be to not get subservient
right as a server you're not a service
provider you're a partner
establish ground rules
um with your partners
um
and like with everything else i mean the
value you provide
the results will speak for themselves
right the more
uh if you are if you are bringing value
to them
and then they want more of it um i think
the i think getting that trust and
as as soon as
once that partnership is established a
key push a key i think another parameter
here is
the data science team and the it team
becomes sort of like
more controlling of our own destiny
because then
we can do the
hard skills data science work and if
that is good then we control our own
destiny so there is a soft skills
portion which is like
um
engaging with them
establishing a working relationship
that is a soft skill thing
then we get to control our own destiny
for a little bit and then the hard
skills kick in
uh hard data science and analytic skills
kick in
to establish and grow that
thank you pravan on this this topic as
well mark i see you put a
a great point into the chat as well if
you wanted to jump in and maybe share
that
yeah sure um
my name's mark i work for a health
system as a data analyst in houston
texas and
um what i mentioned in the chat was that
you know sometimes
um part of like the business
relationship between the teams
uh like the business teams and the data
science teams part of that working
relationship
is understanding that
you know what
the work you do may only be like one of
many factors that play into decisions by
the business teams
so i gave an example of like a model
says do x and they do y instead and
um oftentimes there's a really good
reason for that and just understanding
what that is um
is part of an ongoing conversation
one example um
from
our work is that
we make recommendations on so we receive
a lot of patient satisfaction surveys
we make recommendations to different
hospitals in our systems for you know
what individual units should focus on
for the upcoming quarter based on
um looking at like the variable
importance on what's driving those uh
patient satisfaction scores
um
so we get down to the nitty-gritty but
like the business leaders one thing we
found is that they like to sometimes
ignore that recommendation based on the
most important variables
because they want to have consistency
across all the different units in their
hospital um
so that was really helpful for us to
understand is that sometimes you know a
model says hey you should focus on
like trying to improve this one specific
question
um but by providing you know
all of these different you know
objectives it makes it harder for them
to improve overall so having that clear
consistent um you know one singular
message has been super helpful
thank you mark that's really helpful
thanks for the comment and it is
the
analytics and decision are two separate
steps and they
don't always have to be in lockstep with
each other
siddiqui i apologize if i'm pronouncing
your name wrong as well but i see you
had your hand raised earlier and i just
wanted to make sure we didn't miss you
yeah hi
so you can call me master
so
nice to meet you
nice to meet you
so uh how to
make a good partnership so
i would like to add three points the
first point would be customer first so
whenever you are having a partnership
you beat with them as a term customer
and then uh
what i try from my side but i always
think for them you know if you think for
them they will think that this person is
always thinking for me and he's adding
money to my business to my team and they
will always come to you when they have
any project
per se
so that's a customer first approach
it works everywhere outside inside
uh second is more like a consecutive
approach so
most of the time uh the other partner
the
stakeholders they don't understand what
they want from you so they will come
with a random idea they want they have
this problem and they want a solution
so rather than thinking from their head
you should give a consecutive approach
so when when you do that they think okay
he's actually adding value to me and i
did nothing from this point of view or a
vantage point so then they drop they
start trusting you and you build builder
trust with them
and
one
uh what is it for me so
uh most of the time when i when we work
with like it they will always have
problem you know buying live work for
them
uh so if you come with an approach that
you also have something if you help me
you will get this x and y z
kind of achievement or or addition in
the project
so when you think from that angle they
will definitely help you
so these are three points which i would
like to add here
that's awesome thank you so much for
sharing those too and
i see you're putting those in the chat
as well
i am i'm just
going through to see which questions we
had missed from earlier and i see there
was one on
rachel i i'd like to add something to
what mr said right definitely this is
presenting to executives and business
team right
um
data scientists and
i.t people we have to talk
the business language when we present
[Music]
and
put put the results of the models and
the analytics
in the perspective of the business
language what it means for the company
what it means for their business process
and so we have to
learn their language translate
data model and analytics to their
language to talk to them and i think
both sides need to make that effort a
little bit and
so that's very that's a you know muslim
touched upon this in
using other
say criteria and values but it's very
important
i like uh christian's comment too and
use colors lots of colors they like
colors
um
probably the other question that i saw
come in from slido was
are there common traps that data
scientists or data science teams fall
into
the broad question um
measure yeah so
we you know
many of many of you may have seen like
you know data science is three different
you know this venn diagram there's the
coding part of it that is the math part
of it and then there is the business
domain part of it right so
um
make sure that all three are covered in
a project right so and if
[Music]
that's the capability side of it the
other big trap is
um when say executives come and say hey
can you do something cool with
artificial intelligence or machine
learning so that is a
solution looking for a problem and
that's a trap
right because
um
that
has the potential
for like it has the potential for being
find me a needle in a haystack kind of a
thing um and you go keep looking for it
and
it is ripe for that kind of an
engagement to get to project creep
right um so that's a that's actually a
very i'd say that's the very big
trap to fall into
[Music]
the other thing
let me think here
i think
it is connected to this
finding a needle in the haystack
thing
set a deadline or clear criteria
when to
stop investing in a project
i think it's a it's an off you know it's
a next step to that second point but i
think
um
it's a hard thing to do
but it is almost like a sunk cost thing
but it is a definition and criteria for
having that
stop
thank you
if you don't mind just hop in just add
to that comment
i would also say one of the challenges
is that sometimes
the data scientists always want to
do the the
most interesting model to them to help
them learn but it's also sometimes like
taking a sledgehammer to try to hang a
picture right so choosing the right
model for the right situation i think is
one of the traps or downfalls that um
they fall into
that's a great point scott
and anyone else who has feedback on this
question too feel free to jump in
i think the one that the one in the chat
about visualizations is key
like
it's about
um okay i am the most experienced but
for me i found
i got asked to do
i believe it was a pie chart when a pie
chart didn't really make sense because
of course it just shows like out of 100
actually you want to be able to try and
show more than just the
td pitch and you want to try and
describe it
so what i did is i did a pie chart but i
also did a different visualization so
they have both options
to try and get this is what you want so
i
provide showing that i'm listening to
you but actually this is the way that is
much easier to understand and i can go
to much more detail in him describe this
graph
in a way that you can understand the
same as the pie chart
and that did help quite a bit with
communication wise
because they and they now know that i
listen to them when they
uh ask for stuff yep
definitely i
i love seeing all these recommendations
in the chat too and i know i can't read
them all right now
but i always like go through the chat
after the fact
and want to be better about sharing some
of the feedback and links shared
through linkedin as well
so before i forget to say this later i
wanted to just let you know that i
shared a link to a data science hangout
community linkedin group
there where after each session now i'll
start to like
summarize like on one question or
include some resources
that are there too
but just sharing that because i know i
will forget to at the end
um
but rob keyword i see you asked a
question around delivering value would
you want to jump in and ask that yeah i
think maybe some of this maybe had been
tackled already but
i think
sometimes it can be really difficult and
i was just more curious about
the trust and value sort of link and are
there specific things sort of concrete
maybe almost like a recipe that you're
following that
or if you can turn it into a recipe for
others to follow
what your advice would be
dollars is the when all thing
that's the you know if you have that you
have everything else
the
if you are not able to get a clear way
to dollars
then business kpis
um
what matters to your constituents or
your partners
that
so it's
if i have to rank them so to speak in
order dollars is if you are able to get
to that calculation of dollars great
that's the best case the second best
case is business kpis what
your partners care about
then
much much
um so
one and two are fairly close to each
other number three lags behind in a very
far away land
is model matrix how good the model is
so
that's how i think about it
so
having a
very accurate cool model
um
does not create value
yeah
i think christian also put in there
um you know failing fast or delivering
value quickly because you could have
this conversation and come back three
months later and
as a business executive i've moved on
i'm already thinking about other things
and you haven't
demonstrated
that you can actually add value
quickly so
that feels like an important part as
well
yes i agree yeah
thank you
thank you prabha i just want to make
sure that i haven't missed anyone's
questions from slido or the chat as well
so
as we
get down to the the final few minutes
here and
we can of course stay on a little bit
longer feel free to just raise your hand
or just unmute yourself and jump in too
one question that i i love to ask
everyone prabha is
are there certain resources or
whether that's books or podcasts
or other events like this that you
attend that you'd recommend to us all
um
well
i think from a business perspective
value i can recommend a few books that
i've read in the last few years that are
not
data science books but it expands my
focus of thinking of value and things
like that i would say
top of the list would be prediction
machines
that's a book written by a few
professors from i think toronto or
university up in toronto
another book i would highly recommend
for business value or business
value focused
reading would be measure what matters
that is a book written
i forget the name of the author but it
takes a lot of concepts from
productivity management that comes from
andy grove and in from the early years
of intel from andy grove and high output
management
i would say prediction machines and
measure what matters
they are non-technical books but help
to develop
thinking and approaches and methodology
for value creation
awesome thank you
okay no one's going to jump in i have
one other question i want to ask you and
i know you you said focus on dollars um
especially with like selling internally
and showing business value
but how do you actually
like go about doing that
like how do you
get to the point of understanding
exactly what
the dollar value is associated for for
each project
um
that is an agreement that i make with
my partners at the beginning of the
project
um i
become
we make
you know it just has to be a
straightforward calculation it has to be
a times b
times c or something like that
and then we can clearly measure the a
and the b and the c's
right so
for a given project
and
if we are not able to get to that up
front we are not able to agree on the
a's and the b's and the c's and the d's
then i know
there is a lesser chance of success if
my partner or the business team is
clearly able to say
these are the a's
that multiplied by the b's gives us the
value
and the current value of a is x1
and if we increase that to x2 that can
just get plugged back into the equation
so that is part of that initial scoping
and definition of success
because there are cases where
um you know take this pricing
predictions right so there are cases
where
you know
the model says something and you're able
to go get negotiate and get a better
price it's really hard to at that point
um say how much of
that better outcome for flex
is attributed to model versus the
person who's doing the negotiation so
those are all like really hard
and
my advice will be
spend less effort on splitting the pie
at that point
and
if you are partners then
you got that value or money together
right um and if you if you haven't
agreed upon
a times b times c calculation then that
helps
you don't have to have a
[Music]
contention point at the time of how to
split the dollars so as much as possible
[Music]
create what
how will you measure success before you
start doing the work
awesome thank you so much faba that
that's extremely helpful
i am i just had a something i wanted to
ask the group as well before we go
and just wanted to
ask everyone if you would feel
comfortable inviting someone to
like join us at the next hangout
feel free to share the link with them
which i'll put in the chat but i'd love
if everyone would
be able to reach out to someone from an
underrepresented group in data science
i love to welcome other people into the
conversations as well
and even if that's just one person that
we all invite i think that would make a
huge difference um and just wanted to to
say that so thank you all for thinking
about that and
thank you prabha so much for for jumping
on and sharing all your insights with us
and one second i'm gonna share the link
rachel thanks for inviting me and uh for
the audience thanks for joining and uh
listening and giving us the time thank
you all have a great rest of the day
you